D
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE RUSSIAN INVASION OF UKRAINE
HAPPENING THOUSANDS OF MILES
AWAY AND THAT'S ABOUT TO HAVE A
BIG IMPACT HERE AT HOME AFTER
SLOPPING SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WARNING AMERICANS TO
BE PREPARED FOR ECONOMIC
STRENGTH.
>> DEFENDING FREEDOM WILL HAVE
COSTS FOR US.
WE NEED TO BE HONEST ABOUT THAT.
>> DO PEOPLE EXPECT THAT KIND OF
NUMBERS?
>> AS HE HEARD THE PRESIDENT SAY
LAST WEEK, STANDING UP FOR OUR
VALUES IS NOT WITHOUT COST.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS
MINIMIZE THAT COST.
SO I DON'T HAVE A PREDICTION OF
IT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE ARE
TRYING TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT ON
THE GLOBAL ENERGY MARKET.
>> Dana: RESPONSE TO OUR
SANCTIONS WILL BE PAINFUL FOR
AMERICA AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY IS TELLING
AMERICAN COUNTRIES TO BE READY
FOR RUSSIAN CYBERATTACKS.
AND RUSSIAN TANKS AND TROOPS ARE
"UNCOILED FROM THEIR HOLDING
POSITIONS AND ARE READY TO GO."
BEFORE WE GET OUR REACTION,
LET'S GO TO BILL HEMMER.
HOW ARE YOU, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> NICE TO SEE YOU, DANA.
>> Dana: WHAT'S THE UPDATE?
>> HERE'S THE SITUATION.
IT IS MIDNIGHT AND 1:00 IN THE
MORNING IN MOSCOW AND WE ARE
LOOKING AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
PUTIN IS GOING TO PULL THE
TRIGGER.
THERE WAS A HEADLINE ABOUT AN
HOUR AGO ABOUT FORCES DOWN HERE
IN SOUTHEASTERN UKRAINE
REQUESTING MILITARY ASSISTANCE
ON BEHALF OF MOSCOW.
THAT WAS THE WORD FROM THE
KREMLIN.
HERE IS THE NEIGHBORHOOD, PULL
INTO THE WEST, BELARUS TO THE
NORTH, RUSSIA TO THE EAST, AND
UKRAINE IS THE FOCUS RIGHT NOW.
I WANT TO GO YOU DOME ACTUALLY A
COUPLE SLIDES.
THIS IS WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THE
THE 20TH OF FEBRUARY.
EVERY RED CIRCLE YOU SEE IS A
NEW MILITARY PRESENCE, OKAY.
THAT IS OF THREE DOES AGO.
THIS IS WHERE WE BELIEVE THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY WAS INVOLVED.
THAT WAS PRIOR TO THE CURRENT
BUILD UP.
THIS IS AS OF THE END
OF DECEMBER, DECEMBER 29TH.
YOU SEE THE RED CIRCLE START TO
POP UP.
RUSSIA HERE.
I WILL TAKE YOU TO BE END
OF JANUARY NOW, GENERA 25.
YOU SEE THIS ACTIVITY HERE?
THAT'S IN ANOTHER COUNTRY.
VERY FRIENDLY HISTORY WITH THE
RUSSIANS -- SHE STARTED TO SEE
MORE ACTIVITY HERE.
THEN LET'S GO TO THE IMAGE I
JUST SHOWED YOU A MOMENT AGO.
AS OF THREE DAYS AGO IN
BELARUS -- POLLUTANT HAS GOT A
LOT OF OPTIONS HERE.
WHAT IS HE GOING TO DO?
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POSSIBILITY
IF BELARUS GIVES THE RUSSIAN
ARMY THE AUTHORITY TO CROSS ITS
OWN BORDER, WHICH IS A
POSSIBILITY, HASN'T HAPPENED
YET, OR PUTIN COULD COME IN HERE
THROUGH THE NORTHEAST.
IT CUTS THROUGH THE MAP AND HAS
THE ABILITY, THE PAVEMENT, THE
CONSTRUCTION THAT WOULD ALLOW
YOU TO TAKE BIG TANKS AND BIG
TRUCKS ACROSS UKRAINE.
WHETHER HE DOES THAT OR NOT, WE
DON'T KNOW.
ALSO HERE IN THE SOUTHEAST IS
THAT PUTIN HAS DECLARED
INDEPENDENT AS OF 36 HOURS AGO.
HE'S GOT A LOT TO DO, A LOT OF
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE.
WE DO NOT KNOW.
MIDNIGHT IN KIEV AS WE SPEAK.
>> Dana: APPRECIATE IT.
WE WILL TAKE IT OR ON THE TABLE
NOW.
JUST FROM A MILITARY PERSPECTIVE
WHEN YOU SEE THAT, ESPECIALLY
LATINATE OPPOSITION TO THE
SOUTH, THERE IS A POSSIBILITY
WITH THE SHIPS THAT YOU COULD
SEE ADDITIONAL ACTIVITY.
>> VERY MUCH SO.
I APPRECIATE THAT BREAKDOWN.
WELL DONE.
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE BLOCKS HE IS HE UP IMPORTANT
AND SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT.
THERE'S ALSO AN IMPORTANT PORT
THERE THAT THEY COULD MOVE
TOWARD.
LOOK AT THE DOTS MOVE ON THAT
AND IT'S QUITE CLEAR EXACTLY
WHAT PUTIN'S INTENTIONS ARE.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT, WHAT'S UP
IN THE LAST 24 HOURS, THERE'S A
LOT THAT GOES INTO PUTTING
YOURSELF IN A POSITION TO LAUNCH
A FULL-SCALE ATTACK ON YOUR OWN
TERMS, WHICH IS WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS DONE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE GOAL OF
THE AMERICANS, WHAT JOE BIDEN'S
GOAL HAS BEEN FROM THE
BEGINNING, IT HAS BEEN
DETERRENCE FOR THAT IS THE GOAL.
IF THAT HAS BEEN THE GOAL AND
SIGNS POINT TO WHERE WE ARE
GOING RIGHT NOW, THAT WILL
OFFEND AN UTTER FAILURE.
AND YOU CONTRAST THAT WITH THE
REAL POLITY APPROACH, THE
UNPREDICTABLE APPROACH AND HOW
HE DEALT WITH UKRAINE.
STRONG MEN AROUND THE WORLD
UNDERSTOOD WE HAD STRENGTH HERE.
RIGHT NOW, VLADIMIR PUTIN KNOWS
THE ONLY THING HE'S DEALING WITH
AS DIPLOMATS.
WE THINK THEY CAN TALK THEIR WAY
OUT OF THIS SANCTION, WEAKLY
SANCTIONED THEIR WAY OUT OF
THIS.
NONE OF THIS WILL DETER HIM.
THIS ALL DEPENDS ON HIS
AMBITIONS.
>> Dana: THE SANCTIONS ARE
BEING DESCRIBED AS TIMID, NOT
ENOUGH, BUT I WAS THINKING, DO
YOU REMEMBER THE MOTHER OF ALL
BOMBS, THE MOAB.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
ACTIONS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
TOOK AS PRESIDENT AND IT
SURPRISED EVERYONE.
IT TOOK EVERYONE OFF GUARD LIKE
WELL, HE'S SERIOUS.
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE THE MOTHER OF
ALL SANCTIONS?
>> Jesse: LIVING IN RUSSIA IS
THE MOTHER OF ALL SANCTIONS.
THEY HAVE A TOUGH LIFE THERE AND
THEY'VE BEEN LIVING UNDER
SANCTIONS PROBABLY THEIR WHOLE
LIVES, ESPECIALLY THE LAST TEN
YEARS OR SO.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, THE SKIES
LOCKED AND LOADED.
HE'S SENDING BLOOD TO THE FRONT
LINES, BUILDING HOSPITALS PRINT
HE'S ALREADY USED THE
INFORMATION WARFARE.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF TIME.
YOU ARE RIGHT, WE ARE ALL JUST
REACTING TO WHAT HE IS DOING.
THAT IS NOT A GREAT POSITION TO
BE.
HERE IS THE JESSE WATTERS
WORST-CASE SCENARIO.
WORST-CASE SCENARIO, AN AMERICAN
WHO HAS NOT EVACUATED THAT
COUNTRY DIES SOMEHOW BECAUSE OF
COMBAT IN THAT COUNTRY.
WHAT DOES JOE BIDEN DO IF AN
AMERICAN IS KILLED BY THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINE?
>> PROBABLY NOTHING.
THAT IS A SITUATION THAT HAS
HUGE CONSEQUENCES.
WHAT IF THEY DON'T SEE THAT
COMING?
GOES RIGHT INTO WARSAW, PLUGS
AND RIGHT THERE.
YOU CUT OFF THE BALTICS FROM
THAT WESTERN NORTHERN EUROPEAN
PLAN RIGHT THERE AND HE JUST
SAYS ALL RIGHT, YOU YOU WANT TO
TURN YOUR LIGHTS OFF, YOU'RE UP?
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT EUROPE IS
QUITE UP TO DO.
IT WENT UP TO TURN THEIR LIGHTS
OFF, NOT BY ANY ENERGY FROM THE
RUSSIANS, OR GERMANY WILL HAVE
TO CUT A DEAL WITH THE KREMLIN.
ARE WE GOING TO DEFEND POLAND?
WERE GOING TO SEND PEOPLE INTO
POLAND IN 2022?
MY BEST-CASE SCENARIO IS THAT
IS.
HE GOES INTO KYIV AND STOPS
THERE.
AND WE JUST BLEED HIM DRY WITH
AN INSURGENCY.
THAT IS THE BEST-CASE SCENARIO.
WHAT JOE BIDEN HAS TO DO NOW IS
CUT THE GAS TAX AND HE'S GOT A
DO TOMORROW.
HE ALSO HAS TWO BAG OPEC A
LITTLE HARDER.
HE'S GOT TO START THREATENING
THE SAUDIS WITH SOMETHING OTHER
THAN PLEASE.
IN OTHER THAN THAT, HE'S NOT
GOING TO GIVE DO KEYSTONE, BUT
HE'S GOT TO LIFT THESE LEASES ON
THE FEDERAL LANDS AND THAT HAS
HAPPENED IMMEDIATELY.
YOU CANNOT WAIT.
YOU'VE GOT TO DO IT NOW.
>> Dana: GERALDO, IF WE HAVE
THE CLAPPER SOUND -- IF YOU
COULD PULL THAT UP.
THIS IS JAMES CLAPPER.
HE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN 2014 WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS IN OFFICE,
RUSSIA INVADED AND TOOK CRIMEA
AND THIS IS WHAT HE THINKS OF
THAT DECISION NOW.
>> PUTIN CLEARLY IS MORE A LOT
MORE EMBOLDENED THAN HE WAS
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
AND WE HAVE A LOT BETTER
INTELLIGENCE.
WE AS AN ADMINISTRATION HAVE
BEEN MORE AGGRESSIVE IN 2014.
>> Jesse: YOU THINK?
>> Dana: THEY SHOULD'VE BEEN
MORE AGGRESSIVE IN 2014.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE FIND ABOUT
WHAT WE SHOULD DO IN 2022?
>> Geraldo: IT'S JOB DROPPING
HOW MILD AND MEEK OUR RESPONSE
WAS TO THE SEIZURE OF CRIMEA.
ALMOST AS SOON AS IT HAPPENED
PEOPLE WERE SAYING WELL, CRIMEA
IS REALLY HISTORICALLY PART OF
RUSSIA.
YOU KNOW, THE LITTLE GREEN MEN,
PURPLE WITH MINE, WHATEVER THEY
WERE WERE ALMOST EXPECTED AND
THEN IT JUST WENT ON TO
SOMETHING ELSE HAPPENED AND THE
WORLD'S ATTENTION SHIFTED.
WE COULD -- LET ME START BY JUST
WITH THE MAJOR ON BIDEN.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN'S TEAM
HAS ACCURATELY FORECASTED
EVERYTHING PUTIN WAS GOING TO DO
AND IS NOW DOING.
AND I WHOLLY HOPE THE PRESIDENT
IS WRONG THAT PUTIN HASN'T MADE
THE DECISION TO PULL THE TRIGGER
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT I SAY THIS?
JESSE'S ADJUSTER COULD BE A
MOVEMENT TO POLAND.
WHO KNOWS WHAT COULD HAPPEN.
ONCE WAR STARTS, YOU NEVER KNOW
WHERE IT'S GOING TO GO.
SO I PRAY THAT THIS REMAINS A
RELATIVELY LOCALIZED UKRAINIAN
PHENOMENON.
I FEEL SORRY FOR THE UKRAINIANS.
WE WILL FIGHT THEM IN THE
ALLEYWAYS AND ARM EVERYBODY AND
THE UNCERTAINTY WILL BLEED PUTIN
AND ALL THE REST OF IT, BUT WHAT
HAPPENS?
SOME UKRAINIAN GUY GETS A HOLD
OF A NUKE OR SOMETHING.
OR SOME PROVOCATION.
ONE RUSSIAN GENERAL OVER STOPS
OR OTHER OUTRAGEOUS ACT HAPPENS
AS OFTEN HAPPENS IN ALL-OUT WAR
WITH THESE TANKS, JETS,
ARTILLERY, MISSILES, AND ALL THE
REST OF IT.
I FEAR THAT UNLESS WE CAN STOP
THIS THING NOW, THIS COULD BE
THE BEGINNING OF AWFUL, AWFUL
CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS COULD BE
WORLD WAR III HAS TO START
SOMEPLACE IF WE HAVE THAT
HORRIBLE SCENARIO.
ALL THESE WEAPONS COME ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE DON'T LIKE OCCUPYING
THE SAME SPACE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT PUTIN IS
THINKING AND WHAT HE THINKS IS
GOING TO GET OUT OF IT.
>> Dana: JOHN RATCLIFFE WAS ON
EARLIER WITH MARTHA AND HE SAID
SOMETHING VERY INTERESTING.
HE SAID WE ARE ALL BNS'S
QUESTIONS, WHAT WILL PUTIN DEAL,
RATHER THAN WHAT SHOULD A PUTIN
DO BECAUSE WE ARE IN A POSITION
OF BASICALLY WAITING TO SEE WHAT
HE DOES RATHER THAN TELLING HIM
WHAT HE SHOULD DO.
SPEAK OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTINUES TO BE -- IF PUTIN
MOVES, WE WILL ALSO MOVE.
THEY ARE FOLLOWING FROM BEHIND,
LEAVING BEHIND WHAT PUTIN'S
ACTIONS ARE GOING TO BE.
THEY ALSO KEEP TRYING TO MAKE
THIS ARGUMENT THAT EVERYTHING
WITH THE ENERGY SITUATION THAT
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO MITIGATE THE COST FOR
AMERICANS.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
IF THEY WANTED TO MITIGATE THE
COST, THEY WOULD TURN THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE BACK ON, HIRE
BACK ALL THE GUYS THEY FIRED,
AND GET 800,000 PEOPLE A DAY
RUNNING THROUGH THAT PIPELINE
INSTEAD OF IMPORTING
500,000 BARRELS A DAY FROM
RUSSIA.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO BRING
UP HERE IS UKRAINE AND NATO
SITUATION.
SO FOR YEARS, UKRAINE HAS ASKED
TO BE A NATO PREDICTS THAT, WE
WANT TO PAY OUR FAIR SHARE, WE
WANT TO BE PART OF THE ALLIANCE,
WE WANT TO HAVE THIS ARTICLE
FIVE SITUATION AGAINST RUSSIA
JUST IN CASE THEY DECIDE TO
INVADE LIKE THEY ARE RIGHT NOW.
INSTEAD OF UKRAINE ALWAYS BEING
TOLD, YOU GUYS HAVE TO FIX YOUR
ISSUES FIRST.
JOE BIDEN TOLD THEM COMING UP TO
FIXING CORRUPTION ISSUES FIRST.
THE BIDENS AND OTHER POLITICIANS
IN EUROPE, THE UNITED STATES
PARTICIPATED IN IT.
THEY GOT RICH OFF OF IT.
AND NOW UKRAINE, CIVILIANS THERE
ARE GOING TO DIE AS A RESULT OF
THIS CHAOTIC SITUATION WHERE
THEY WERE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE LAWLESSNESS, THE CORRUPTION
IN UKRAINE, NOT FIXING IT,
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GO IN AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE CORRUPTION,
RIGHT?
THERE ARE CERTAIN RULES.
THEY LET UKRAINE HANG OUT THERE
SO THEY COULD ALL GET RICH AND
NOW THEY ARE SCREWED, THEY ARE
SURROUNDED.
I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT.
THEY'VE BEEN ASKING TO BE A PART
OF THE ALLIANCE AND THEY'VE BEEN
TOLD NO.
WHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS GOTTEN
RICH OFF OF IT.
NOW THEY ARE IN A POSITION WHERE
THEY ARE -